I love April Fool's I tell you a funny
story to know if you crack up that's
when I lose it okay okay don't worry
okay we'll stay this one hombre someone
sent you it's worker gram okay but let's
get to twerking and what's up Oh God
and if you look at the crest you'll
notice that under this hallowed word
there are three bunches of asparagus Wow
how's the fool again yeah you know when
you're a kid you like all one day I'm
gonna be signing all these girls and
them nope not me I think roots
I wasn't ready pleasure
I love April Fool's but the thing about
it is is I love doing but my April
Fool's runs the entire year I see yes
yeah because it's like April Fool's
everyone's expecting it so this past
around Christmastime we're getting ready
to make a big announcement for a movie
and I called my agent I was I was over
season I call my agent Brad Slater woke
him up in the middle of the night and I
was like hey man I got to talk to his
like what's going on what's wrong I said
I don't know how it happened but my
cousin who was on tour with us I said
just got busted with prostitutes and my
name is attached to it now and it's all
getting ready to hit the press he
started freaking out I was like Brad are
you okay he was getting emotional oh my
god what are we gonna do okay hold on
and he goes I'm gonna be calm in the
pocket I'm thinking about this hold on
and I was like I don't know what to do I
think there's multiple prostitutes with
this thing there's a whole ring over
here it's unbelievable
had him going and going and going and
finally I was like Oh Brad Brad Brad
he's like what I was like December Fool
you dig it it's a like that and there
was a long time I had breakfast with
Archbishop Desmond Tutu and lunch with
Nelson Mandela Wow
and actually when he came to the state
yeah the last time he came came to
California came to our house well that's
pretty good I tell you a funny story too
it would be mad at me for telling this
but I'll tell it anyway yeah it's the
bestest alone he lives up and they were
like in a gated community he lives over
there and he wasn't invited but we had
about maybe 40 50 people there you know
and I had my children I said you can
invite one friend and Oprah Winfrey
different people were there and the
security I have security helicopters
like it was the president yeah they're
like mr. Washington Rockies out front
he's pacing
so we he's like should we let him in I'm
like yeah that's the best
without looking sad yeah
oh boy good do you train really hard in
the off season can you give me any tips
anything you can talk about oh it's a
whole town and I don't work I just sit
on the couch you you thought you had
something going right that you were one
of those like was Linda that you know
made us generation work hard not with me
anyway I didn't get inspired no all I do
is really just take care of the kids you
know I won't say no if Andy Murray
decides now all right he's a nice guy
ROG he's a father and let's I won't
but
he'd like to win the first four British
Tennyson's what is 850,000 years so I'm
just happy waking up in the morning and
feeling like an old man so that's very
positive felt like you're looking right
at me when you say that thanks buddy
appreciate that you know that old little
house he hittin him he warmed me up and
I won I still think the interview was
great
but then I needed Roger to stick around
so I could ask a few questions in
Spanish for a CNN in espanol programming
does you don't have to do anything I'm
just gonna read out some questions on
Spanish just a couple of questions while
while you're in shot okay um I don't
need to answer them no you don't need to
answer them at all here we go rooster
this one hombre right on yeah no it's
okay I can I can keep going even if
you're smiling that's when I lose it
okay that's why
Challenge Sargam challenge Bill Gates my
partner Facebook's Sheryl Sandberg and
Netflix is founder and CEO Reed Hastings
I'm glad to give to ALS it's a great
cause but I want to accept this
challenge I want to do it better than
it's been done I've been working on this
you know got this design there we go
yeah it's gonna be great
I'm here to join the people bringing
attention to Lou Gehrig's disease by
taking the ALS ice bucket challenge I'm
gonna challenge three more people Elon
Musk Ryan Seacrest and Chris Anderson of
Ted consider yourself challenged you
have 24 hours good luck
it's at the Sun cuz he's my best friend
he's my best friend
is it true that you can leap over a
chair from a standing position it
depends on the size of the chair I'll
cheat a little bit
gentlemen the movie is testing through
the roof we're gonna have ourselves a
hit right I just want to say it's all
thanks to this guy man I've loved
working with you right straight up you
know when we started this movie you and
I were co-stars now you're my brother
all we need now is a title okay well why
I mean best to keep it simple know it's
like Drake and Blake yeah we could cause
yeah maybe but I also like Blake and
Drake do we have a law
Blake things like Oh or do we like
genuinely love Drake and Blake like
right when you hear it why don't we just
take the beginning of my name and the
end of your name and just Blake BAM
Blake just gets like it's like hard to
say you know it's like black black and
Drake what's like Drake and Blake
drinking bleh guys guys guys go hey you
know what hey we have a week to make
this decision I mean I'm sure something
will happen to make Blake change his
mind
oh something's gonna happen
something's gonna happen it's all
hey cutie Hey
someone sent you its worker Graham okay
well let's get to 29 what's up Oh God oh
wait wait I thought this was a car
commercial Steve the teller
Slate's up please and action
there you go it's a great day everyone's
happy and look back look at the horizon
look at your career look what you've
become who cut his hair for this that's
whatever all right once the anesthesia
kicks in we will be removing the
patient's appendix but first there's
donuts in the kitchen guys what oh god
you're the surgeon oh I'm not the
surgeon he is
Breezie the Internet has killed you for
doing too much flapping how do you
respond to your critics I would like to
say as Blake Griffin that I love floppy
you know I mean there's so much demanded
of me that you know a lot of the time
it's just better for me to fall down and
take a little rest hey what's up
everybody I'm Drake and this message
goes out to all of my fans you I really
don't have much integrity they try to
get me to do the NBA Cares commercials
and I always kindly decline you can
climb the NBA Cares I'm not really I'm
just not into children all right all
right all right let me lay it down this
is the new sound of Drake right here
skee bop shoo bop bop bah bah bah I am
drink and I like you girl I think a lot
of people are extremely confused about
my face I kind of look like a black guy
that jumped into a pit of Cheetos and
just laid there for for like 10 days and
then popped up
I tell people I'm half-black but really
I don't know do you know what team has
the most white players because that's
probably where I want to go I'm not sure
you're gonna have a career after this
and let's print that I like it a lot I
think that's gonna be great I think it's
really gonna up my street cred so what
do you think Donald Sterling's message
was that not all people are equal and I
agree with it I'm actually glad this has
been filmed
anyway I'm Blake Griffin part of the
dominant white race and I would just
like to let so even now I have no idea
why I was asked to speak here today I
prepared to speech very carefully the
way that any good Dartmouth educated
graduate would I drank a 40 of
Jagermeister then I called my dad to see
if he would get me out of it he's here
today he could not get me out of it
so I tried to hire a college freshman to
write it for me in exchange for a two
hundred dollar gift card to Newbury
Comics that didn't work out finally
seeing that I absolutely had to do this
and couldn't get out of it rolled up my
sleeves sat down at my computer and
tried to buy a commencement address off
of moving commencement speeches calm my
credit card was declined so I had to
write the thing myself and here we are
today there are many many distinguished
speakers who have spoken here today I am
sharing the stage with Preet Bharara US
Attorney for the Southern District of
New York we've heard what a great guy he
is in 2012 he was named by Time magazine
as one of the 100 most influential
people in the world which apparently
they're just giving out
according to time he's battled terrorism
as evidenced by his conviction of the
Time Square bomber he's crippled
international arms dealers drug
traffickers and dealt with financial
fraud clearly Harvard wanted you to see
the full range of what India can produce
dear mr. Brar fights finance criminals
and terrorism
I meet handsome men in cute in unusual
ways on television and next season my
character might get a pet puppy so is
one more important than the other
who can say the real reason I am here is
as Connie said I am obsessed with
justice not so much with the law but
with justice actually in my mind law is
that pesky thing that often gets in the
way of justice
I believe in the Clint Eastwood School
of the law an eye for an eye I don't
think so that solves nothing
you take my eye I take your life my
friend okay in a duel Aaron Burr style I
don't want your stupid eye for what my
eye collection you're dead okay
yes duels are the first thing that you
learn when you enter my graduate program
the harvard school of vengeance but
again that is not what I came here to
talk to you about that's for the
reception after we can talk about that
more the Harvard Law School crest which
you can see in front of you is um it has
the word Veritas which means truth in
Latin I know this because though I have
been known as Mindy my whole life my
first name is actually Vera which means
also means truth it's true it's actually
too boring to make that bag up and if
you look at the crest you'll notice that
under this hallowed word there are three
bunches of asparagus
because asparagus is the the tallest and
the proudest of the vegetables the
pillar of the vegetable kingdom and it's
it's liked a lot okay that is done that
is not asparagus that is that it's wheat
which makes also not a ton of sounds
either okay well that was like three
pages of my C speech nope okay that was
that's a callback to asparagus I have
this really funny run about hollandaise
you'll never get to hear that you know
this isn't going anywhere I'm gonna move
past trying to make sense of your crust
which makes no sense so I'm going to
Montgomery to play called the promoter I
said I'm broke down I said I don't know
how long it's gonna take to fix it and
it was about 2:30 or 3:00 o'clock for
the evening then I said but I'm pretty
sure that we'll be late when we get that
heat that's alright B come on up there
now you show come on come on
so sure enough we were late when the bus
got ready and we went on up there when
we got there
yeah that we had something you called it
you don't hear much about them today
honorees only a lot of this honorees so
the armory you started from the ground
floor and you had to walk about 10 or 15
stairs and there was a platform like it
so that's what he was set to collect his
tickets in the money and then you go
about 10 or 15 more flows and there's
the the dance hall okay so when I got
there I said well we made it easy Abbas
you can turn around go back now because
I know pay you gonna be this late easy
well I have AZ in general but I said
well since I'm here I have a you know a
thing about being late I have a thing
about
you know standing up to people I said
let me go on I'm play okay gonna be one
of it I know pay us okay so we went on
upstairs born we got on the dance floor
and it was just people was just look
like that packed in that while sure
would like to have some of that money so
we can upset and we started the plan and
the people you know you couldn't buy
like a big chair you what they called a
brown bagging carry okay your bottle
with you Oh at the Armory they had
places we could keep your bottle you
know yeah when we got the plane and
people started drinking a Yaqui doctor
everything was going to it zapped I
played about two or three people these
days you know and they everybody was
fired up man I said ladies and gentlemen
so you know this is all be and I had
never stood you up no be you always come
in times yeah well I had something I'm
sad to tell you but when I came upstairs
the boss told me when won't pay me
everybody got quiet what
so no he said he wasn't gonna pay me and
now I ain't telling you what to do but I
feel that if I'm play free he should be
able to listen free you know San Diego
famous and I love you plan hey y'all
check on your money do a petition boy a
little bit later the money went one way
and a dude went the other again I was at
the airport and these huge Irish dudes
start pacing around me sounds like all
right it's gonna go down at the airport
here we go and then go I I think they're
Australian so let me change the
Australian action I you bro laws
they say could you sign on for arms I'm
signing these like rugby players for
arms and like yo that billionaire song
you are legend oh my god signing page
signed any other body parts in forward
to that yeah you know when you're a kid
you like on one day I'm gonna be signing
all these girls and them nope not me
big brutes oh well you know I try to be
an artist I moved up to California to be
an artist so I'm writing these songs and
they're all for me never wanted to be a
producer never thought about writing
with other people for other people so
I'm writing the song with me I got
approached by a label that heard one of
these songs and they said look we want
this song for another artist we don't
want you know we don't want to sign you
we want to take your song and give it to
another artist and at the time I was
working a cab for the first time and you
know as a songwriter she's written you
know so many hits and I talked to her I
said Cara my music this is my music this
is my art she looks at me she says stop
being up she says no one knows who the
hell you are
you have no story sell your freaking
song what is it through a song you're
ever doing yeah and so you did and I did
and then that paid my rent and that got
me to stab here and got me you know so I
owe a lot to Kara DioGuardi and the
writing credits that you are mounting
since then she's dead right yeah thank
you care calling me in 1983 when we hit
the eight percent saying I don't know
that I've ever told this story before
but Sam Walton came down to my office
and he said do you think anybody in the
company remembers that I promise to do
the who look we made 8% and I said
everybody in the company remembers that
and he says well you got me into it so
you arrange it and don't screw it up
and and left well I had a trip that I
had to make to to New York and so we got
up there and we staged this thing and
there was press from everywhere I've
tried for three months what I thought
for two months that it would actually
happen but our numbers were just barely
8% pre-tax he's going oh four and
everyone in the company said mr. Walton
you've got to before we did now you do
it
I'm fulfilling an obligation to our
employees I wagered with him a year and
a half ago that in the year 1983 they
never could possibly achieve a better
than 8% net profit corporately
indeed
okay don't stumble run
no one has a clue
we're on pocket and pocket
yes hey good luck oh man
get us out a little at the left
I'm gonna play what
wait
when Sansui
yah-ha look
whoa
oh let's see punish the girls oh yeah
what fun
whoa cassabi that's it relieve leash
what
come on come on hey obvious move you
they go I mean what
or dilemmas
thank you so much for watching I don't
think we as entrepreneurs often have
enough fun in our business I know we're
focused so much about our big goal and
where we want to go and the stress of
maintaining the business and getting
customers and you know keeping the
lights on but I think it's important to
have fun in your business on a regular
basis and it was fun for me to put
together this series of clips so
hopefully you guys have some fun I love
to know what you think if you own leave
a comment below I'd also love to know
how do you have fun in your business
what do you do to keep it fun leave the
comment below I will join in discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon